were people of faith joe biden and i
kamala harris said the other night at
the debate
that's not true democratic party is a
secular party i'm not attacking them
it's just obvious a lot of democrats are
highly
highly hostile to organized religion and
a lot of them deeply resent amy coney
barrett for her orthodox catholicism
but they've decided not to say anything
about it because it's an election year
so they're trying to keep it under wraps
it's a political calculation
obviously but what do they really think
well privately democrats are fixated on
amy coney barrett's religious beliefs we
know that
in part because today dianne feinstein
the senior senator from california
didn't realize her mike was on and let
the mask slip
here she's
it's deeply personal and it comes with
her religion
like it's a disease
we shouldn't be surprised dianne
feinstein said this and by the way
catholicism is one of the few religions
you're allowed to say this about
in 2017 feinstein told amy coney barrett
that religious faith was quote a concern
i think whatever a religion is it has
its own dogma
the law is totally different
and i think in in your case
professor
when you read your speeches
the conclusion one draws
is that the dogma lives
loudly within you and
that's of concern
the dogma lives loudly within you not
the dog
the dogma lives loudly within you
in terms of sheer inc coherence and
stupidity it's almost like a mazie
hirono
impression honestly the big secret in
washington
is that a lot of these people dripping
with credentials like third world
generals and their medals
are actually not very bright so what
does amy coney barrett really like
ann falgus has known her for a long time
she's been close friends with amy coney
barrett since college and we're happy to
have her on tonight and thanks so much
for coming on so it seems worse since we
you know we've gone through day after
day of hearing
talking about uh amy barrett's legal
philosophy
getting a sense of what she's like as a
person and since you've known her for
decades
we thought we'd ask you well
i thought first of all thanks for having
me on i thought she was absolutely
superb
the past few days in the hearings she
demonstrated her high
intellect she was humble it comes across
very very well to everyone i saw some
polling today
saying that across party lines support
for her has grown
in the country and she's you know she is
a faithful catholic
but she shouldn't be attacked for that
there's no religious test
in this country for public office and it
shouldn't be
an issue sincerely religious
people live in general much happier more
productive lives
add rather than detract in what world is
that a bad thing
i mean most of the people in this
country are religious
and live religious lives i think that
there are a lot of people in this
country on both sides of the coast for
example
who have gotten away from that
but they miss what's happening in most
of the country um even at our own
college at rhodes college we had
a group of alum come out and say and
call her a theocratic
bigot they wanted the college to disavow
her
as an alum one of our most prestigious
alums of all time if not the most
so in a few of us who know amy very well
started alumniforaamy.org to get some
signatures and send them today to the
senate judiciary committee
on her behalf including justice scalia's
grandson who's a 2018 graduate of rhodes
college
and you know we're still taking
signatures but
through her confirmation but we just
wanted to show the senate judiciary we
wanted to show rhodes college she wanted
to show amy
that were behind her it's a bipartisan
letter
it goes back and talks about how
wonderful she is
as a person the achievements that she
has attained
in her life um you know she it
rhodes she was on the honor council
which is a big deal
we voted her on junior year and senior
year
and from our class and then our senior
year she was voted school
campus wide to be the vice president
interesting well she's continued on that
trajectory
and thank you for that great to see you
tonight that's hurtful thank you
college alums